we'll start at the top x squared minus X
minus twelve if it equals zero when you
say solve what are you searching for
what are you looking for you're
searching for expert not just any X like
there are specific values of X you only
want specific ones what is it about
these why is two not a solution or 1 or
0 okay if I substitute in that
particular value of x like a 1 or 2 this
is not true
1 minus 1 minus 12 is not 0 right so it
doesn't satisfy that original question
that's what I'm searching for the best
way to be able to find that is to
factorize now will point out just like
I've mentioned before for a nice easy
monic quadratic like this where's Monica
MIMO Monica 1 referring to UM the one
that's actually implied at the front
there for a nice easy monic quadratic
like this you think of your pair of
numbers you can go straight to this line
right 3 and negative 4 they'll multiply
to that and they'll add to that okay so
there aren't our solutions and you can
test that you can put in 4 16 minus 4
minus 12 it's zero right so I'm happy
we'll come back to 2 you guys gonna have
to help me out down here or even stopped
us out with one line of working what
rule is that do you recognize it it's
the cosine rule which is why it starts
with cause we were marking some tests
during the yearly and people use the
cosine rule except they started it with
sine because sine rule has cosine oh no
you can see he has to use all three one
two three of these signs there's an a
novena see does it matter which one a
and B are it doesn't matter which one a
and B are why not it doesn't matter
which one a and B are because you do the
same thing that a that you did a B you
square it and you add down here you just
multiply same thing okay but to see you
do something different you subtract it
and it's not there on the denominator
of course for your sake not mine
because I know because I walked around
and I had a look a lot of you do not
know how to do this so I want to make
sure you do that big fraction will give
you some work for your calculator to do
your punch that in there's a there's a
an operation on your calculator but you
have to do to get from our aims first
line to his last line
what are you gonna have to put on your
calculator after you evaluate that
fractions you have to get a shift cause
to undo the closets on the left hand
side
do I have agreement with 81 degrees 56
minutes yes did we run it correctly
great okay you guys are going to help me
do question two you're gonna help me
work out what's right I'm gonna leap
straight into the quadratic formula
because I look at that and I think gross
even if it ends up being something I can
factorize the quadratic formula will
still give that to me okay so if we go t
equals how does the quadratic formula
begin - B there's be right there so - B
will be positive 4 plus or minus why is
there a plus or minus in there because I
took the square root when I completed
the square and there's a + and there's -
right there's the square root you just
taught me about what's underneath this
where it okay B Square which in this
case is in this case 16 takeaway for AC
which is 4 times 3 times negative 1
that's 12 isn't it so that's actually
I'll put them negative 12 there is that
okay there's my b squared minus 4ac all
over what - a 6 okay so far so good now
I can work with this thing underneath
the square root 16 take away negative 12
is 28 very good on 6 and I can tidy this
up a little bit see this square root of
28 there's a square number I can get it
out what's the square number 4 so if I
take it out the square root of 4 of
course is 2
which leaves me with a square root of
seven which means I can I'm not even
gonna rub bother writing it but I could
write that as two plus or minus root
seven on three that make sense maybe I
will write it just for the sake of it
done okay you happy chords ready for me
I got to know that one like the back of
your hand okay